it's men who are responsible in the
first place to
bring about the change in this world men
were sent as prophets
all prophets were men um it is in
accountability as a responsibility
the best example is a processor so you
look at that you look at
omar uthman all the sahaba khali one of
my favorite hamza
you know one of my favorite hamza was he
was a lion hunter for god's sake you
know what i mean he just smashes abuja
you know he's just i've done my degree
in biology and psychology
neuroscience and cognition okay and i've
done research as i said in parkinson's
so i've looked at you know human
cognition behavior
family psychology
early child psychology then i've done
education
okay a degree in education and
curriculum
then i've done a bachelors in islamic
studies
sharia then i've done additional
qualification in counseling
uh in existential counseling positive
islamic positive psychology counseling
finishing now a degree in positive
islamic psychology counseling here in
malaysia
doing a master's also in education from
the university of malaya
inshallah hopefully finishing up this
year in islamic curriculum
and counseling in islamic schools
and now all of a sudden they took the
red pill and they wake up and it's a
reactionary movement so what they do is
they bump on they jump on the other side
and start pressing people they start
talking
smack the things that are not good they
start committing sins and they because
it's reactionary see for islam
masculinity is not a reactionary thing
so i had a i had a dream one
one night that i was and i got stabbed
and i died you know and then
i think that's the one that really it
was so vivid and that's the one that
really uh
pushed me to say you know what god if
tomorrow i die am i really
you know i know what's right why am i
hesitating i really fed this is our
our dojo here
bag we got you know
wow so you know enough space to spar and
everything it's like
it's quite big 100 we have four bags
and uh you know like our sparring stuff
here and whatnot yeah
that's what's up man
[Music]
i want to speak about things i don't
know about but allah says in the quran
chapter 17 verse 15 at the end
is very very beautiful verse at the end
he says never would we punish a people
until we sent
them a messenger so if somebody doesn't
get the message they are not punishable
that's why in the beginning i said let's
use the example of someone who rejected
islam
this person got the message of islam
like abu jahl was arrogant and rejected
it they said i don't want to believe in
it
that person is punishable but if you
have a person who is like
seen by allah as a good person and um
they didn't do any atrocities they were
a kind-hearted person
and all that but they didn't get the
message of islam they're not punishable
but for them it's a test on the day of
judgment and that's that it differs from
person to birth
salaam walaikum ladies and gentlemen
welcome back to t3m
you already know who the three hosts are
but we're joined here with a special
guest today
uh gabriel al-rahman how's it going
aloha
yeah so uh gabriel man i've been kind of
following you for a while watching your
videos
on youtube tremendous work you're doing
for the muslim community
i found a lot of benefit from your dawah
but for those of uh
our viewers that don't really know you
haven't seen you yet
uh why not a quick summary and
introduction
okay
name of allah the most christian most
merciful so my name is gabriel
it's born in romania eastern europe um
what about 37 year old now mashallah so
i was born in 1983 in a different
millennium in a different century
alhamdulillah and um moved from romania
to canada i've undertaken my education
in canada started high school in canada
um
that is also where i've met muslims for
the first time
in my life uh coming from romania i
hated muslims i hated islam because
that's what we're
taught to do you know that was part of
our um
of our upbringing our history our
literacy everything has to do with
muslims being
terrorists and you know the same type of
stuff that you hear today
so coming into canada i was able to meet
muslims alhamdulillah
and see a contradiction between what i
was taught
and what i experienced which obviously
caused some doubts for me
and helped me to look into it more so i
embarked on a journey let's say about
five years of
solid research praying very spiritual
a lot of guidance from allah you know
where i kind of left christianity
just praying to the one creator you know
which i always advise people to do when
they seek the truth you know
to just put all everything aside and
just pray to their creator
and alhamdulillah by his blessing you
know through the dawah of
a very good brother and other brothers
you know some a bosnian brother
and some arab brothers i was able to
embrace islam in my first university
which was a
big uh help for me it
really saved me you can say because man
first universe is very tough
alhamdulillah so alhamdulillah i
undertook my
studies in uh biology psychology
neuroscience and cognition i've done
research in parkinson's disease
and i went on to do a degree in
education
and then yeah so the first year i
converted to islam then i did a degree
in islamic studies alhamdulillah
later on and education i became a
teacher
moved to the to the middle east where i
started to
work and allah has blessed me
to you know just you know study there
embrace the culture
uh live with the bedouins and just i
fell in love with you know just with the
culture i was able to travel
to 40 countries al hamdulillah from that
hub because it's so easy
you know all the way from the west to
the east
and to work with them you know my
passion was education and
psychology development
and i think that's where i identified
especially dealing with my students
i think my my best times for me was when
i was a teacher
and so i thought in the west in canada
usa
and then i taught in the east you know
in the far east and that's when i
realized that we are
having the same problem you know people
tell you that oh in the west we have
different issues you guys in the east
have different issues you guys don't
know what you're talking about don't
take from the east you know
take from the west stuff like that i
don't know like they don't know what
they're talking about like they're just
i call them what you call they're just
travelers like
just tourists you know just kind of
stopping by here and there
if you get to live with the people you
get to know that we're having the same
issue so i asked myself okay what i
position myself
in this ummah as a new muslim at that
time
and how can i solve some of the problems
that's what my skill sets my studio
education and psychology right i
understand the human brain the human
psyche
how it works and alhamdulillah you know
i understand education
and i was blessed to to study some you
know islamic studies alhamdulillah
so i said okay let me combine this and
see how i can solve the problem
of you know in the world and that was
i started with the problem of identity
was in general
a crisis of identity within the muslim
ummah
okay then again
introspecting traveling you know people
started seeing someone more
my work i started being called to like
huda tv peace tv dr zakir naik
so i did some shows which were quite
different
and they liked it was you know one was
called sunnah style
and the other was called uh meshech
or problems of the youth youth problems
and that was like aired on saudi
and all over so sometimes my students
will come i saw you on tv you know
it was like translated in arabic and
whatnot and
i think it allowed for the students to
connect to me and to open up and to
to see that okay we can kind of like
talk to these guys so then
a lot more is coming towards me you know
a lot of issues
um i realized that in the in the east
for example
a lot of issues of of sexual orientation
homosexuality and stuff like that and
the students in the muslim students
confusion uh westernization
you know the lack of understanding islam
there's just so many problems but all of
them would come to the issue of identity
you know
and post colonial you know trauma so
and i said okay what else can i i need
to it's quite general it's too general
and i need to focus a bit more how do i
focus this a bit more right so i was
working with
okay schools and becoming a you know i
was a school principal i became school
principals and i was exposed to more
issues and more problems within the
systems as well looking at the systems
and i got to understand a lot more
so then i said okay so i'm working
education i'm a school principal
dealing with curriculum you know
traveling to muslim countries
uh and became a school consultant so
people would call me to help them
when they're you know setting up schools
or you know systems or
product projects for youth youth or
anything like that
i said okay it's still quite general you
know still quite general
and then um i was doing khutbas as well
during all this time and people would
come again after
the hotpas and start opening up to me
because of the subjects that i would
talk about
in the hotbah like i'll talk on the
member about some of these things that
i'm talking even now in my
in my lectures you know and so parents
would come
youth would come so i connected the dots
and i said okay
let me look into the dao scene and
what's happening so i saw a lot of
people talking about mashallah and siam
and km
and you know we need that we really
really really need that right
and then i saw that not too many people
are talking about marriage and social
issues
psychology you know nuts
and uh the problems they were facing
identity crisis the the attack on the
ummah
be it from the liberals the lgbqt
community and seoul many things that are
somehow connected
and then i realized that
we're suffering as muslims from a very
very
severe problem and that is we're losing
our fitrah
you know we are losing the way allah
subhanahu has
created us you know allah has created us
in a certain way
and that that fitra
is key if it stays intact
i believe that people can
and do receive revelation much easier
they understand islam easier and they're
willing to come to islam
much much easier as soon as you mess
that fitrap
then i believe that it becomes much much
harder for people to accept
you know when allah says something or
the prophet
uh says something right so that's for
both muslims and non-muslims
then i narrow it down a bit more and i
said okay what can i do as a man i
realize i said my god you know
having worked with boys and boys schools
especially in the middle east
i said we are losing our masculinity our
fitrah
so i said let me focus as much as i can
on that so i counsel right now i'm a
counselor
i'm a school principal and i try to
combine all my work on this kind of one
thing you know how do i
bring back or protect the fitra of males
people i say why males
because i'm a male number one okay and
because
allah says it's men who are responsible
in the first place to
bring about the change in this world men
were sent as prophets all prophets were
men
um it is in accountability as a
responsibility so
that's why i think there's a systematic
war against masculinity it's systematic
this is not a conspiracy theory it's
systematic
it is in education it is in the health
care system it is in the media
and if you don't wake up we're going to
be losing
ourselves so you know the reduction of
gender gap gender roles
so many things comes under political
agenda under a
social agenda legally
but in the end it is a clear war
on masculinity so basically my work
revolves pretty much
around that beer that's in the school
dealing with the students
okay and yes i do talk to to to two
girls as well i mean i have lady
students who come to me and
sometimes they feel more comfortable to
talk to a man because they say okay what
you're saying is it's true
and we don't want to talk to the girls
because the girls are just too you know
and to themselves they just they
they wanna they want me to do what they
did or they want me to go through the
same failures or problems that they did
so we can connect on a feminine level
you know
so i do i this is the truth i deal with
within a proper halal environment uh you
know there's there's a lot of problems
that so yes women will
realize that hey you know what this is a
problem and i think
uh we need more of this so alhamdulillah
so i deal with my students i deal with
parents
and i deal with people from all over the
world as a counselor
and from all walks of life all
all you know cultures are muslim who are
who need help and support in islamic
you know counseling psychology to help
them understand the fitra
and how to to fix any issues be it dnb
is social
and what not and of course me being a
new muslim
of course a lot of the people that i
come to me are going to be new muslims
and that's another
you know kind of it's a different
problem but yet it's related i mean new
muslims
i'm sure for you guys who are you
muslims maybe any one of you converted
islam
you know that in the end your past is
quite hard to forget you know in
psychology we call it a total past
learning history
you know the total past learning history
is something that defines who we are
today
and you know alhamdulillah for the
guidance of allah
that kind of controls and reshapes you
know
our psychology in the present but indeed
sometimes you know some things you
cannot
you cannot forget so some of the issues
that new muslims bring forth are not the
same as some of the issues that
people are born into and the muslim
family are but
they're still connected so alhamdulillah
recently i released my book
journal of a new muslim that deals with
some of these things some of my memoirs
and some of my
thoughts growing up as a new muslim you
know as a young man
because i became muslim when i was like
what 19 20.
it was quite early and i started
researching islam when i was 13
14. so that time was a very very
turbulent time a lot of depression a lot
of anxiety
like i've gone through depression three
times in my life severe depression
that's why you know when i connect to
people or i
counsel people have depression i'm like
don't worry i know how you feel you know
so anyway the book focuses on some of
these issues it's quite
a personal book it's quite it's
basically my experiences
and talking about i talk about
masculinity talk about education talk
about new muslims
talk about marriage the difficulties of
around marriage these days
so in a nutshell that's pretty much who
i am and what i do i live in malaysia
right now
i'm a school principal for alhamdulillah
integrity school
in kuala lumpur and alhamdulillah i love
martial arts i love to stay fit and
working with a lot of men to help them
to come back to masculinity
fitra um you know the the sahaba style
the way that the companions the process
and war that's our standard
so alhamdulillah you know this is some
great work that we are doing together
and i'm very excited i mean every every
day i wake up
and i'm just excited to
be given this opportunity by allah to
serve people
to help them and and to connect to them
and it's just so rewarding like you know
just 2020 was a tough year for many
people
because of the lockdown it was just an
excellent year for me and i don't like
to rub it in people's
faces but it was just the best probably
one of the best years of my life you
know
i've done so much it's just so much
improvement in terms of it and you know
my own personal studies
my development my work my finances
things like that you know things went up
and down but alhamdulillah
it was just great so this is uh gabriel
for you martial
so yeah man for all that
it was a wonderful introduction uh so
two things i want to get out there and
one we can connect with you definitely
and we can relate to you in the fact
that
waking up every day and serving others
and spreading the truth
are helping the ummah and helping
non-muslims it truly is
fulfilling and it's rewarding it's it's
something we're very new into
but we're we're beginning to see how how
rewarding
it is intrinsically
and uh the second thing is i got a quick
question for you so you mentioned you've
been a reaper for
17 18 years right uh okay
so everyone has a turning point when
they when it just clicks for them
when they know that okay there's no
doubt that islam is the truth
so for you when was this turning point
what was
what was going on during that what was
it for you
okay so as i i told you guys i moved
from romania to canada so
that was a quiet day and again i think
looking back
at what happened in my life at that time
i feel that
allah subhanahu talam brings us to
certain points in our lives i think
every human being goes through this
you know they have this this uh
you're kind of like at a crossroads you
know everyone's thinking okay this is a
time where what is the point in my life
why why is this why are these things
happening everyone whether they're
poor or rich whether they're suffering
whether they're healthy or sick
at some point in your life you know the
human being is going to
ask himself this question like is there
more to this life than this
you know right so for me that point came
quite early and
some things in your life will speed that
process
and facilitate that to happen and some
others you know i mean there's
great many people who live in like
beverly hills and drive porsches and
whatnot
but still they do stop and they're like
you know what the heck is what's going
on what's what's my life for is it just
for this porsche and this house
and you see that you see that on media
you see that in you know that people
do come even if they're coming from a
higher social class
so for me at that time my parents just
divorced
uh my brother was you know into drugs
and you know he became a gangster and
what not you know because i guess that
was something that
he was being brainwashed all the way
back from romania
the american you know concept of you
know being a thug and being cool and
whatnot so he went that way
and i was um you know with my mom
and i was working full time like i mean
14
13 14 i started work working full-time
since then i didn't stop like since then
i've been basically working you know day
and day and day and day
and it was tough you know because we are
immigrants we were
new to canada and yes we're white
caucasians but subhanallah it's so weird
you know like
uh my mom experienced so much
discrimination you know
there's just so much racism and
discrimination in the west that is just
crazy you know people don't understand
forget about people are of color you
know
that's even you know crazier uh people
don't understand
so like we we had a hard time you know
i'll be washing dishes at night and i'll
be studying in the morning
i'll be working in the factory you know
and the trash you know at
night and after school and i'll be
studying in the morning so
it was it was quite a tough time so that
time kind of
pushed me towards questioning certain
things and meeting the muslims you know
helped me to question my background and
what i was taught
and canada being a bit you know more of
an open country i started researching or
library taking books i would hide them
under my pillow because i was
embarrassed to be honest and i don't
want my mom to know like i was
i was i was considered a very religious
christian person in my family like
my mom would come to me as an adult and
ask me for advice
you know what i mean like she would be
like the first person i've ever
counseled you know
like proper counseling you're talking
about like a two-year
you know session with her when going to
my father's divorce you know where i
would walk her to
work holding her hand and walk her back
home
so it was a tough time and that time
made me think a lot and it was that time
when i abandoned christianity because i
realized that
it was not the truth i was going to a
christian school a christian theological
school
discussing with the priests discussing
with the religious teachers
uh discussing with the muslims on the
other side and basically i just said
okay this is this is not it
this is not it i'm not yet gonna jump
into islam so i started studying all
kinds of different religions
but i knew that it's the christianity is
not it
i knew that god exists no doubt i mean
really you have to be a fool when you
look around
in the world just simple just look at
the sunset and the sunrise
that perfection of that system to think
that there is
you know there is no creator or
something like that it's just
there's no way there's no way so that
was not a doubt in my mind whatsoever
and um i think because i was coming from
that spiritual background christianity i
was praying a lot
and while doing the research while
talking
and of course this is not necessarily
this quite subjective but allah was like
guiding me
i had certain dreams that were happening
certain intense experiences
where again i'm not using it as a proof
when i talk to people islam because
that's personal
but um it was just so powerful
and you know it was just pushing me to
look more and more and more and more
right so i think it's about
the first year university where finally
um and i was reading the quran every
single day and i think the one thing
that really got me was that
i was trying so hard to not come to
islam
you know i was trying really hard
because you know i had the girl
and i had the car and i had the
popularity you know
i mean yeah it was cool i was driving a
nissan 300 zx in
grade 12 you know like i was i was i was
pimping you know as
as a grade 12 guy you know i was uh you
know
very i was in the newspaper i was
playing football i was a you know
superstar in the soccer team and
you know i had a girlfriend my
girlfriend her father was a promoter for
boxing from prince naseem hamed you know
so they were you know they're bawling
and it was like
you know cool my brother was gangster
like
everything was like wow you know and i
was looking for an excuse
not to you know and i was reading the
quran and
i remember it was like a war like every
day i would try to reach like a page
and i would stick to that and then i
would just like be
so excited to get back to it at night
and read again
and i felt like it was reading me you
know like i felt like
i thought i'm gonna read it and just
like find something and then just put it
off you know
but i felt like the quran was was
talking to me was reading me and
especially like with the difficulties
that are going on
and at that time i was i was on the
outside it looked like i was so
successful and so amazing
but on the inside i was i was dying you
know because
i just felt that god was calling me i
was denying it
i was confused because of the you know
the you know
all the lies that i heard my whole life
and i changed i left
christianity you know the problems with
my brother the problems with my family
and i was just so depressed you know i
was just so depressed i was even
contemplating suicide
that was the first and only time i kind
of thought about suicide you know
and i was quite young you know and i was
like what tech and i went to a doctor
you know i went to the to a psychologist
and he just like he didn't put his hands
on me just like looked at me and he said
you know
okay just take this medicine and i was
like what tech you know this is not good
that's not how you do it
right most people still today they still
say that that's how the shrinks and the
psychiatrists work
they just give you medicine and just you
know take it so i was
in a huge depression and i think
you know that that helped me so much it
was such a blessing
from allah to open up because i was so
arrogant
and if that would have not happened that
arrogance would have not been in check
because
yes i looked there again i behaved
arrogant i was so successful
but inside i knew that i was breaking
and that
like wait a second like i'm so weak you
know what i mean i'm not that strong
like i need divine intervention and it
was at that time
reading the quran that i was like
realizing that you know what
that's it you know so i had a i had a
dream one one night that i was
yeah and i got stabbed and i died you
know and then i think that's the one
that really
it was so vivid and that's the one that
really uh
pushed me to say you know what god if
tomorrow i die am i really
you know i know what's right why am i
hesitating why am i
stopping myself and i think many people
bros you know
many people that i met over the past 17
years are in the same position they'll
say something like
islam is the best religion you know like
if i were to pick a religion it
is islam but i can't give up this or but
i can't give up that right i can't do
this i can't change that you know they
think you have to be an angel to become
a muslim you know
and that's why my strategy is like look
man don't worry about it just take
shahada
no but i drink i'm like don't worry
about it just take shot no but i have
girls i'm like yeah i know me too i had
girls you know
you know that's what that's the truth i
mean when i became muslim i still
you know i was still you know on the
scene so
people just need to take the step you
know they
you know you know it's just your heart
your mind
everything knows islam is the only thing
that is real
it's no fairy tales it's no like a
sunday thing or saturday thing or friday
thing
it deals with real life unless real life
problems and that's why the whole world
wants to shut it up
wants to quiet it because it is a
solution
to humanity's problems and people don't
want solutions because if people figure
out how to solve their problems
personally then they don't have to pay
this one or that one or they cannot be
controlled by
you know a group of people so definitely
that's why people want to acquire islam
down
why you don't pray or why you don't pray
why don't you don't do salah
and he was talking about how a lot of
brothers and sisters are like oh i'm
gonna do salah when i quit alcohol or
i'm gonna
do salah when i quit gambling and he
keeps saying he's like no
do salah anyway i don't care if you
mentally think you're gonna be a
hypocrite
do salah anyway and salah will bring you
away from those sins
and you know that's that reminds me of
what you said when you do the shahada
then you become a muslim
then you have that guilt you got that
guilt going that okay now i can't drink
or now i know
i'm doing something wrong so there's no
more like okay when i become a muslim
i'm gonna stop now you become a muslim
and that makes you stop
yeah no no no you gotta just take the
take the step you know and i think
a lot of people are caught up in this
and the shaytan is very smart he's gonna
try to
make you think that you're hypocrite and
as you said right there's a difference
between someone who's like
praying and just showing up like you
know that
you're just putting up a front versus
someone who is generally struggling
you know what i mean like they're
struggling with alcohol they're
struggling with pornography they're
struggling with zinna
like the people that i counsel man like
i'm talking about suicide depression
anxiety
then porn drugs alcohol zina
homosexuality lesbianism you name it bro
but these people are coming because they
want to stop
there's a difference between someone who
knows that they're you know they got a
problem
and it's a war you know there's a war
inside the
quiet chambers of their hearts you know
there's just this huge jihad that's
taking place
and they're trying to fight it and
there's a difference between that person
the person who's like you know
conscious it knows that i am just going
to pray just so you know show people or
just
appear by it you know be hypocrite
that's a big big difference you know
so but the shaytan is smart he's going
to tell those people i see her hypocrite
you know don't pray
stop you know lose hope stuff like that
and that's his
that's his objective he wants to smash
you you know he wants to put you down
all uh
so i know i really want to go into
masculinity right now because
it's it's a very good topic that i feel
like more people got to be
aware of and and enlightened on but
before we go on i know animals
so it's okay if you can't fully answer
this to the extent that
the other two do but i got a question
for all three of you
so the question is i want you guys to
tell me one big problem that you see
in today's muslim man because i know um
you know brother gabriel was talking
about how we're losing our touch with
the fitra
so my first question is you know what is
a big problem
all three of you see just one in today's
muslim man i want you to then give me
one problem you see in today's muslim
woman as well so we'll start with angel
then rami and we'll end it off with
gabriel dude i think i have no answer
because i am too fresh
i don't know how about that oh no i mean
before romney gives us his two cents
how about just in today's modern man
period
the average man so what's the biggest
problem with today
just one more then i want you to give me
one for for women
uh for men
pornography
and for women it is
polygamy yeah
there it is yes
you already know what uh what some
comments are gonna be like but anyway
rami let's go with you yeah subhanallah
i feel like any problem that men have
these days are either going to be a
reflection of a lack of
masculinity or a lack of islam lack of
understanding in islam
because if you practice islam as a full
practicing muslim you're bound to be in
your masculine because the
responsibilities you have
to you know uphold so those are the root
causes but
a lot of the time one of the biggest
problems i see with men
is one complaining about issues and two
forgetting they are the problem solvers
right because a lot of the i see a lot
of men complaining
about what other men do and about what
women do and they become kind of black
pilled
and they don't understand that okay
you're looking at the end result right
the issue starts here
and here's what you could do to fix and
better your life but a lot of men
nowadays they just complain
whether it's about islam or about their
life they're just complaining
what about women women specifically
muslim women today yeah i feel
i feel they're also complaining except
they're complaining on the other end of
the spectrum right so again it starts
with a lack of understanding of islam
and two i feel like a lot of them are
blaming men
for problems that they're unwilling to
accept as women
right and a lot of the time like the
whole discussion of mad right
it is there to protect a woman it is her
right but
they forget something like it's supposed
to be light it's not to keep it light
because it's supposed to protect you but
it's not supposed to you know murder the
guy he's not supposed to put him
financial debt he's supposed to support
you right
um and so on and so forth but i feel
like the issue is the reason i said men
is because a lot of the time women's
issues start with men
because as men if all good and bad
things start with us
that's the problem women have as well
and a lot of the time there is
things like domestic abuse from men but
if a woman a lot of the time this is
what we talk about if a man's not in his
masculine the woman's not going to be in
her feminine
right so again even then even then it
kind of starts with the man
as the leader but again women are held
accountable and
uh it's hard to summarize it but it goes
back to
i think feminism then trying to be the
man is a big issue
he's the youngest one of us and uh looks
like he's the most woke
so far i'm just playing and then gabriel
i want to hear your
your opinion on it yeah i totally agree
with my brothers mashallah i think
they're very specific
uh sorry how do i how do i pronounce
your name
uh because in romanian the way your name
is spelled angel
is like a proper romanian name you know
yeah yeah it's like that
but it's on angel i'm here
are you uh latino yep
yeah okay because in romania is the
angel
yeah it's uh it means angel right
it does yes yeah that's the same thing
in spanish
we got a whole lot of peeps pronouncing
your name
angel angel we got a lot of different
ways
just
okay um so i totally agree with you guys
i'm gonna be a bit more general like i
think
for both and in my counseling i always
say to couples if you guys can fix these
two issues on both
sides then things can everything else
can be solved
number one is the issue of akida you
know i think people
don't understand that's tied to what
rami said like knowledge you know like
people
don't know and you know that people
think it's like okay uh let us discuss
and debate certain things and this and
that
it's very theoretical is so much more
it's
a lot of it has to do with practice you
know so you believe something and then
you
implement that you know
you know like allah keeps going back to
that
and those who believe and do or practice
the righteous deeds right
just the concept of salah people say i'm
praying no allah
throughout the quran doesn't say you
know
okay usually we say you know there's
a system there's of implementation right
so i always say if your akita's
correct and you implement it you
understand who is allah you understand
your deen
as uh as angel said is like
you know there's then you understand
allah is watching you understand
issues of responsibilities you
understand the sisters yeah they'll have
uh jealousy but they will submit in the
end
right because this is the thing islam is
submission it's not about like yeah
everything is going to be
fine and dandy it's about submission you
push yourself you work yourself to
accept the rulings of islam
you know what i mean and slowly slowly
do you do internalize them
and slowly slowly becomes part of it
right people think it's just
okay you just make the transition so
simple you know move from here to here
no
it takes time right so i say the number
one thing again number two
number two it's six okay it's six
and i always tell couples if sex is good
intimacy is good so akida you guys are
compatible in deen
so the man is his dean is good the woman
her deen is good
if intimacy and sex is good and men
don't need to go to pornography
women don't have to worry about you know
other stuff
things are okay you know so actually
subhanallah 17 years out of counseling
and dealing with couples and
if these two things the couples are
compatible and they can fix these issues
every other problems family this culture
that uh job money maher this that
in the end all these things can be
solved but if you're not compatible when
it comes to your knowledge and
application of islam
if you don't fix that then
it it triples into it trickles into so
many problems right and then if your
intimacy is not good
because i mean look at that right so
what does allah subhanallah has created
men
has taught men okay then he has given
him a woman
right do you see it's like okay
man is there he needs knowledge okay
he's got a woman
and then they come together what's the
what's nikah you know what's what's the
building block of this
of this of this nation this umna why are
we suffering is because
the individual building block of the
family of the ummah is suffering
the family's suffering the community in
turn is suffering the ummah
is suffering in turn right and people
sadly because of the
as as angel said you know the cons
things such as pornography and
media and you know sex has become
something dirty while it used to be
something so beautiful and knowledge to
be called making love you know now it's
just called you know
either the f word or this or that or so
much
you know and we've all been affected by
that like come on when i talk to my
clients i'm like look man we've
all been affected and conditioned
because of that you know what i mean so
it's a big problem these two of these
two are solved for both men and women
these are two problems
if they get fixed i think we can deal
with the other problems there's a lot of
other problems
but we can deal with everything else
[Music]
there's indeed a crisis of masculinity
among men that i really want to go into
right now
but i know the other two weren't uh as
involved so far uh because we were all
taking our time just listening and you
know
just paying attention man because we'd
love to hear you talk about before you
go in on this
do y'all have any questions anything you
want to note off
on what we discussed so far i just want
to put
emphasis on what brother gabriel just
said because
i feel like it's going to go over the
heads a lot of people but like i want to
emphasize it even more the issue of
al-qaeda
fundamentally right is either it's gonna
make or break
a people person uh you know as a whole
because think about it all fights hatred
whatever it is
is based in a disagreement and now take
that disagreement and make it the
fundamental belief of your purpose in
life and everything around that
people are going to literally fight toe
and nail or teeth and nail whatever the
saying is
because of that but if we can agree on
rasulullah and then dispute on little
issues and not have a big problem
we would be way better off in the time
of um
i forgot what the the leader was but it
was soon after the prophet said
the son of um
they sent him to a people who were
fighting horribly about akida
right fundamental issues he went to them
he said listen all you stop focus on the
quran
and they came together because they all
believed in the quran
so if this is true for an entire nation
of course it's going to be true for
marital relations you know
friendships all so on and so forth and
then obviously
intimacy is a big part for everybody so
i don't think that really needs to i
don't really need to say much
but um those two points i i really want
people like i want to drill into
people's head
those are the most important things
which is why every time someone comes to
me
i tell them register for i3 or go to
some dollar course and learn the
fundamentals before you learn the
rulings and all of that because a lot of
the time it
ends up pushing people away but that was
my my two cents at the end there
real quick for anyone uh any of our
viewers wondering well play that means
like translation in english
um akido theology part of me
like your your core belief your theology
yeah yeah
i was going to say lingard was most
important yeah linguistically
it's um it's i believe it's what the
heart is tied to
that's what it means linguistically but
conventionally it does mean you know in
islam it's a
belief okay
you got anything
romney you're in canada yeah you're
drinking
i see you drinking tim hortons bro
that's killing me
so real quick where were you when you
lived in canada because i i grew up in
toronto
uh i'm sure i'm sure even anna's heard
of toronto
come on now and uh then i moved to a
city called mississauga
and i currently live in waterloo cool
yeah i was in windsor most of my life
oh man that's close to the border yeah
yeah we're closer but i lived in toronto
as well but my brother was in toronto
for a long time
do you like winter toronto better at
toronto
yeah i think
is nice too windsor is more american
yeah definitely man it's like it's like
detroit or michigan it's like
it's back yeah the backyard of detroit
100 i know people that like they just go
across the border to
grab some chick-fil-a or grab whatever
and i'm looking at them like bro really
they can't even do that now because
we've covered but now you can yeah we
used to go for lunch
lunch to him traffic or something like
that you know an arbor all the
other places there's like little arabia
no little yemen
okay man let's let's create a scenario
so you have a kid growing up today
they're born into a muslim household and
this kid's like six seven years old
and from a very young age let's say his
father is either not in the house
his father works overseas because you
know he's like oh i'm providing so
you know let me work in saudi or
wherever and uh
you know he doesn't have a father figure
growing up so
who's he gonna turn into for you know
learning how to be a man he's gonna turn
to mama he's gonna turn to society he's
gonna turn to media he's gonna turn to
pornography
he's gonna turn to his his friends and
let's say he's 18 years old now
and he's pretty much the opposite of
what
islam would have wanted him to be the
opposite of what
a real man as a father would have wanted
him to be
and there's a lot of issues you know we
can talk about you know how we got there
we can talk about
um you know what we can do now but
the main thing i want you to answer
right now um before we go into this
uh is as a father what are the main
things that people are
slipping on today that we're not being
mindful of anymore
okay i think there's there's a big
misconception when it comes to
to the world today and the way they look
at parenting
and specifically the role of fathers and
i i think again you guys can disagree
with me you know
i'm gonna bring my my proof and my
evidence right you guys can disagree we
don't all have to agree
and i know that um you know checking the
comments
in my videos a lot of people you know
they'll try to attack me and
i'm sure people will comment on this
video as well no issue
alhamdulillah you know it's okay you
know as long as you
you can back up what you say then it's
okay
let's let's put it out there right and
let the best argument win
you know and i think that's something
that we don't have these days anymore
but anyway i think there's a big
misconception because see
a child is not raised by a father and a
mother a child is raised by a community
okay and there's a there's a old prophet
they used to say that
you know you raise a child the village
raised the child you know
and you look at the life of the prophet
sallam and the sahaba again that's our
standard
we go back to it when people come and
say yeah but this study says this and
so and so said that i'm like yeah but
have you actually done any research
yourself do you know
how research comes to be about you know
that you can fudge studies and there's
depends
many different companies who pay for
studies to be made in a certain way
and whatnot so be careful with that that
you know just because something is
researched or put out as an article is
not the revelation from allah subhanahu
talaha so be careful with that
right i challenge researchers okay
because going back so
can a child who is raised without a
father
be a strong male yeah i can because imam
mahmud was
raised by their mother you know what was
the difference there was a community
around them
so his mom could point out so she used
to put
hima on imam ahmed and send them to
attend the
lectures of samadhi and says look from
you know
thousands would attend the the lectures
of different scholars and imam ahmed
would be dressed as a little sheikh
going to the
you know and his mom would tell them you
know and there's many things you can see
like he's walking by himself
uh you know he's being exposed to
different things i used to walk to
school four kilometers one way
you know when i was growing up in
romania and that
that made me who i am today today we
won't even let our kids go out in the
backyard man
you know like we're so scared right it's
it's it's crazy
so yes a child if if the community
has males who are strong and that can be
good examples be it the imam of the
community
be it the neighbor be it whoever right
and people work together
and that's the concept of an um
you know there's town you come you
collaborate the problem is we don't have
that
right so so what's the so then what what
you know do we just like smash the
muslims and then say blame the man and
all that no
it's we need to fix the problems from
where they need to be fixed you know so
yes can a boy be raised properly he can
if there's a
male figure and many male figures in the
community who are real
and the mother can point out as well as
off going back to my initial problem
that i said
if the woman has a proper ajida she's
not going to be sitting around the house
and say
you know your father is not around i
feel so bad
i'm crying you know he's such a bad man
he left me alone because women do that
you know whether they like it or not
they're going to be crying their heads
out and whatnot
and letting the kids hear and see that
so what happens is in those formative
stages
the kids start developing this hatred of
masculinity
this hatred of their father figure okay
i just gave you the example of
that sahabi that woman who her her
husband came from jihad and her son died
that day and she put him in a room
and she dressed up for her husband and
you know fed him and he asked how's my
son doing he said she said
he's sleeping which is true she didn't
lie he was sleeping he was dead
okay and she made love to him that night
and she got
pregnant that night and only in the
morning she told them right because
she had akida she understood that that's
i'm not gonna like
crash down my husband has been you know
missing for two three months
you know establishing the dean of allah
and now he comes home knocks the door
the first thing i do is jump on the
floor and you know crash down
you know what i mean so because they had
akida they understood so women will be
rubbing into the face of the kids
they'll be using the kids
a proper woman who understands her dean
she's going to understand
okay my husband he might be in saudi or
something like that that's another thing
we can talk about men going and working
overseas the reality is though that a
lot of the sahabas were missing for a
long time long periods of time from
from home this is the truth and one of
the sheikhs actually did a study
on how much was the process of actually
spending with each wife
keeping in mind his military actions his
travels and so on so okay again the west
today
we ourselves are conditioned or all the
man has to be like
you know at home more and this and that
it's not like that man
it's not like i'll tell you why it's not
like that because the prophet salallahu
didn't do that and still those sahabas
were the best and many of the sahabas
who were raised within
like abdullah bin umar you know where he
was
and many others who were young and who
were raised and who were even born in
medina some of
them so we do have that generation that
was you know had the terbi of the
process
of the sahaba you know being raised so
and they were the
the champions who brought the dean to
the rest of the world after the prophet
you know died these were men but they
saw men
and they were taken care by men right
and their wives their mother didn't
you know rub it in their face that your
father's a bad man and he's not here
and crying all the time you know mama
what's wrong mama
are you crying about daddy you know and
they're like
no but he left me oh i don't know if
he's coming no
you could say your father is a real man
who is establishing the deen of allah is
providing for us you should be proud of
him
okay that's a different conditioning if
he hears that at seven
eight years old when his his mind his id
his
ego is still changing neuroplasticity
the mind is slowly growing the
connections are being strengthened
so he's growing up thinking his father
is a superhero
who is working for the sake of allah
who's providing
why how do you have a roof over your
head because your father is breaking his
back how you have
you know this and that because your
father maybe he's not the perfect guy
look uh zubair and asma they divorce
they had issues
many of the sabbath the prophet divorced
you know the the
i mean there was problems don't think it
was gen on earth
i don't know why people expect that it
was jannah the time of the prophet said
it was not
i think we don't study the syria we pick
and choose our imams give us
the cute stories on you know the things
that can make you laugh and joke and
this and that
people don't study sira and hayatu
sahaba in depth or
you know sadly it's not like that
because oh my god i have to be
politically correct and you have to be
careful
but in reality bros i think if we go
back to that issue if
the woman is playing her part and she
highlights the achievements of the
husband in the eye of the child
whether the husband is there or not it's
not about
quantity it was always about quality the
prophet saws tell him subhanallah
when ibrahim was dying he was not in the
house yet he had to be called
so he had to go he was already doing his
thing
so yeah he did he cried did this and
that and you know then life kind of
moved on
right and no one held it against you his
wife didn't say oh you you were not in
the house my child was you know fasting
right
subhanallah you know like things are
happening you know what i mean
so it depends on how we look at our
situation and how
we what do we highlight so if a woman is
going to highlight that oh my husband is
away
and i'm suffering i'm crying then yes
the child will grow up
with trauma emotional trauma that's
going to be inflicted there
it's gonna hate masculinity a lot of
them turn to homosexuality because they
hate that concept but
true manly men okay so then they go to
like oh i feel like i'm a woman i feel
more feminine
more in touch with my femininity you
know a lot of the guys who are raised
only by mothers
around sisters will feel that okay
it's not about quantity guys about
quality when that man shows up whether
it's you know every week whether it's
masha'allah every two days whether it's
once a month and the woman
looks and all at him and says masha
allah you know
my husband may allah bless you fear
allah
give us halal guys you know line up
respect your father
kiss his hand okay respect him this and
that the guy sits with them not like
he's gonna go on his phone and
he's gonna sit with them he's gonna love
them he's gonna kiss them he's gonna put
him on their lap
he's gonna wrestle with them he's gonna
spend the time that is there with them
he's gonna
throw some boxing throw a baseball
whatever you know like that's gonna
count you know what i mean and that's
going to leave a huge impact and when
the sun grows up
he's going to say my father and
subhanallah you see this in like the
arab cultures a lot of time you know i
don't know growing up with
with the arabs in the bedrooms you know
there's this respect for the father and
the male figure it's changing now
because they're being also attacked and
and destroyed by media and whatnot but
you know 10 15 10 years ago when i was
teaching there like there was still that
you know what i mean
there was still that and i loved that
you know i really loved that
seeing that so i think i i think that's
the problem i think that's the issue
i don't think it's an issue of men not
being present now not
to say that yes there are a lot of men
who just run away
that's a different story again right
there's a lot of men who escape who are
cowards who don't want to take on
responsibility we're not denying that
we are not denying that that exists
but we need to address the problem where
it really starts you know it's not
you know someone's fault one person
there's just so many things that are
interconnected so many issues
and we really need to hit those issues
in the head
and try to solve them and i think then
we can actually
try to make a change but till then we're
okay we kind of know what's the problem
but
we don't have the correct medicine we're
not applying in the right way
that's facts man and i see that with
women all the time left and right in
today's society it's like
when things are going south and it hits
the fan with their man
instead of solving that and fixing that
and working on that
they they do this complaining thing that
you said oh daddy's doing this or
or you know your dad's not home enough
or this and you know she can complain
all she wants and
instead of us just being like okay she's
weak the person that's weaker is gonna
be the other man that comes by and he's
like oh really your husband's not there
for you
okay don't worry i'll be there for you
or you know and it's like it's
ridiculous man there's men like that too
and i see that in women too like when
things are good
cool you don't see them on social media
you don't see them out there they're
focused
when things are you know not the things
are turbulent with their man
they're posting a lot of provocative
pictures on instagram you know
you know you see them out in the clubs
more and this is this is an issue man
this has to stop but
with that being said i want to talk
about how you said
women got to give that man respect dad
respect but how can
men become that man that is worthy of
that respect
well see again if we go back to the
concept of knowledge
and we understand what a real man is
i mean look i know that there's a huge
movement now even among the muslim guys
who are waking up and talking about
masculinity about red pill you know
and a lot of guys are going the red pill
uh
see that's not our standard though there
are some good things there
because it's linked to the fitra and you
know i think uh
you know angel was saying like you know
he doesn't have a lot of experience he
was not talking about islam but he was
talking just from a masculine
perspective
yeah but that's that's exactly what
we're saying like there's a lot of
connection because it deals with the
fitra you know the way
men so be a muslim or non-muslim men are
suffering from the same issue
right so yes the red pill has some good
things in there
and you know but for us as muslims
we we fine tune things because of the
the revelation because of the fitra with
linked to the
quran and so when we want to establish
what is the real man the question is who
is a real man
what is a real man well then we need to
look at the prophet sallallahu alaihi
right because yes the prophet sam was
masculine he was strong
he was you know uh a person who was in
shape and so on
but at the same time he was very much
you know
an emotional person there's hadith where
he cries that his beard is wet
you know they are you know he's he's
protecting
orphan the women you know the the
orphans the children
you know this beautiful hadith where his
little girl takes his hand and walks all
over medina with him and just
complaining and telling him things you
know
i mean he was a proper outright
gentleman but yeah and you see sometimes
some of these guys when they go into
like
masculinity you know women are this and
women are dead and trash and we just use
them and throw them
and some of the muslims are getting into
that you know what i mean because
they've been
their whole world their whole time 10 15
years whatever
they were you know not men they're boys
and now all of a sudden they took the
red pill and they wake up and it's a
reactionary movement so what they do is
they bump on they jump on the other side
and start pressing people they start
talking
smack the things that are not good they
start committing sins and they
because it's reactionary see for islam
masculinity is not a reactionary thing
it's not something that you wake up to
it's something that you have to
get your tarabia in line with you know
we have to
put it into our you know curriculum you
have to put an education our parents the
men have to understand
and it goes back to knowledge again
knowledge and application so you look at
the prophet
the s example is the processor so you
look at that you look at
it
one of my favorite hamza you know one of
my favorites
he was a lion hunter for god's sake you
know what i mean he just smashes abu
jahl you know
he's just proper you know alpha you know
but these men had
ethics and standards they had morals
they were not gangsters you know what i
mean
they are not like oppressors they they
were people when you would say
allah like they would faint or something
like that you know what i mean like they
were people
who internalized the fear of allah
subhana tala
but it didn't make them weak today you
find the imam and the sheikh and so
oh brother i'm very humble uh brother
you know i'm very pious you know this
and that he has masha'allah praying and
knowledge but
when it comes to like so you know oh you
know like they cannot stand up
they cannot they cannot stand up against
oppression or
and that's why we're all backing up
sorry
like you're right so something happens
and and
they chicken out you know what i mean
they ca so and that's why our muslim
communities are being changed so fast
because some of these brothers who are
in responsibility
they're not saying heck no man this is
my limit you're not passing by
you're not passing by me oh why you
think you're so cool no it's because
there's a responsibility
in it
to everything and everyone refuse but
human beings take have taken it so if
you cannot do if you don't have the
strength and step down but the problem
is you know if you don't
but that's that's it that's our standard
our standard is there
you have to have knowledge you have to
have bravery you have to have a vacation
right so when we put that in perspective
i think we know what's a male and how
and we put it in our system
fathers teach it imam's teaching where
is the khutba about masculinity bro
when was last time you heard an imam
giving a khutbah
about masculinity you know people will
be talking about things that are like
not relevant you know it's not about
like quoting hadith in quran yes
alhamdulillah
but how you connect that to something
that is applicable or that's happening
in our community today
you know without compromising your deen
without washing things down
without you know it's like i don't know
some of these hot butts or panel lights
like
it's demand supply you know okay
brothers uh
wife's rights everything is about wife's
rights these days you know everything is
about like what
women what kind of rights they have
what's going on that's not what it's
what it's about wife's right or men's
rights or this is about what is true
what happened how do we raise real men
how do we raise wheel women
you know because mashallah today it
seems that the girls are more masculine
than
the men you know they start getting big
muscles and start fighting and punching
people and saying
i demand my right and this is you know
feminism is a huge you know cancer
that's
that's affecting us so i think we have
the blueprint we have the standard we
know what we have to do but we're not
doing it you know people the ones who
are
responsible for educating the community
are always saying we have to be
politically correct
we have to be careful yes i agree i'm
careful i'm not
you know dumb i don't jump in and start
talking about weird stuff
but at the same time if someone shows up
at my house
and wants to burn down my house yeah
that's not gonna go down without a fight
tonight like
i will fight you know and right now
we're in this intellectual fight
that we need to take on because we're
losing our boys and we're losing our
girls
you know we are losing i get kids coming
to my i got two girls
the other month coming to my office and
saying that they want to get married and
they want to adopt a child
you know what i mean and they're just 12
years old and i'm like well how so
well you know it just we feel like that
you know and then
you dig a little bit more and then you
find they're watching some weird stuff
on netflix and whatnot
and then that's what they're thinking
you know so it's a problem
and some people say well i don't see a
problem yeah heck it's a problem it's a
huge problem
see two girls coming into anyone's
office and saying they want to get
married to one another
that it's taboo in western society to
talk against that
and to speak against that it's it's
almost abnormal to
resist that and feel some type of way
about that and we're conditioned in a
way to just be accepting and be whatever
and
here's the thing at the end of the day
what do you what do you wanna you gotta
compromise one
at the expense of the other you wanna
either have truth and you know
struggle in allah's cause and
rasulallah's cause and islam's cause
or you want to study uh struggle and go
for conformity
and political correctness and you can't
have one
at least fully without
neglecting the other and i go to khutbas
too and you're right man i see
i see no you know talks about
masculinity porn nothing
and i see the same thing happy wife
happy life
[Music]
yeah but you know i mean
you people have to be smart you have to
study you have to understand
how to talk about it yes we're being
opposed
on many but we allowed it you know what
i mean
the issue is that you can intellectually
fight it it's okay
and in the end you know the angels are
gonna ask when you pass away what did
you bring forth and the people are gonna
ask what did you leave behind
you know these are two legacies one you
take forward as per the hadith
one you're gonna leave behind you're
gonna be a yes ma'am
type of guy you're not going to leave
anything behind and most likely you're
going to compromise your dean you're not
going to bring anything forward
okay and this is the sunnah of allah all
the prophets
had to stand their ground you know
all the prophets conflict is part of our
nature
conflict is part of our nature either
you get good at it
this is different than you know violence
and and and oppression i'm talking about
conflict
you know conflict has always been part
of the human nature
it's how you manage that conflict how
good you get at it
and you know the way you do it prophet
sallam was a warrior
he had to all the prophets muslim
everyone in the end
even jesus the prince of peace that they
call had to turn over the tables
and make a whip out of the courts and
whip the you know the the tax
you know collectors and the the people
were selling and exchanging money in the
in the market
you know what i mean so it is what it is
you know what i mean
so when these people come if we are weak
and cowards and we give up
we will pay in a currency that's very
expensive and that is our children
and our iman and you see it right now
i'm not worried because i don't say
let's let's kill this or let's
do that no you don't call to that that's
it we're
intellectually fighting you uh
you know and we will you know and that's
that's just the way that alhamdulillah
people are waking up alhamdulillah many
women are waking up
and you know they they start saying
things like you know what what you guys
are talking about is very important
it is man all it takes is though for
someone to stand up there
and just speak the truth and people will
wake up and those who don't then that's
their business
you know what i mean but people do wake
up people do people start with like i
don't like this i hate this
okay makes sense i think i need this i
want this
100 i agree with you right and that's
what happened like i used to get crazy
heat when i put out the polygenic series
i know
angel was talking about religion you
know when i put out my politicians here
is
man that was like i almost lost my job
man i got a warning you know i got a
warning letter from the board of
board directors you know and i'm in a
muslim country in a muslim school
okay i'm in a muslim country in a muslim
school i got a warning letter
signed by the chairman of the board of
directors
saying that i'm causing fitnah and i'm
like okay so wait a second so
your sons and daughters going to thai
massage places getting you know
finishing massages is not fitna right
and all the prostitution that i see
around in your muslim country is not
fitnah
but me talking about how there's a
solution
to this you know promiscuity and it's
called politician it's a fitnah unless
you're a muslim i can understand if it's
not muslim but you're a muslim
right and then with time that with time
you know
sisters were attacking this night but
then after quite some time i started
receiving messages you know what
i got so upset at the beginning i was
fuming
i was throwing things in the house i was
just gonna you know if i could see you
in front of me i'll probably stab you or
something
but after watching all the series i
gotta say i agree with you right so
people will change people change because
the fitra you know is is is flexible
if we're being attacked from one side
and these guys are pushing their agenda
then we will
be pushed down if we pull them up
towards the truth
then people come people come no
for anyone watching this right now
that's uh you know let's say they're in
the teens or they're
the young adults you know in uh just
early adolescence 12 13 14 all the way
up to 18 19
they're probably still living at home
you know they're just
learning how to you know get in touch
with their fitrah get their iman right
uh what are some biggest pieces of
advice you have for them
okay so as i said again i'm going to go
back to the same issue number one you
need to seek knowledge
like you need to seek knowledge
contextualize knowledge you need to
study the life of the process and
specifically
okay if people are just teaching you how
to recite the quran and just tajweed and
don't understand anything from islam
then
it's a big problem alhamdulillah allah
has blessed
us to not study like that we studied by
understanding
you know contextualizing seerah was a
big part a huge part of our you know
curriculum
and you know tying the ayat of allah to
those incidents that really really made
a huge difference
so number one knowledge number two you
got to build courage you know and
you will not build courage if you're
comfortable okay
i'm not saying some people hey you have
some financial issues maybe you're
living at home
this and that that can be a strategy it
depends on where and what's happening in
your life you know what i mean
i'm not necessarily going to look down
because people some people are suffering
some people are strong this and that but
just life circumstances problems and so
on but
you know you don't be sitting in that
bed
waking up at 12 you know 11 a.m every
day and so on
you know get your back up you know make
sure you have discipline islam teaches
this
like the concept of salah you know
or prayer at its time you know as the
prophet said this teaches you the
greatest lesson of discipline you know
things have to be done
within a schedule so wake up in the
morning i would say that's my greatest
advice
for a man to become a real man wake up
in the morning early
do it day in and day out okay that's
number one
become uncomfortable okay if you think
you're comfortable why why do i say that
just some some red pill stuff no because
the prophet sallam
did not have a comfortable life the
sahaba did not
just oh let us sit here and just chill
you know no
they expose themselves to things that
are uncomfortable
when you're uncomfortable you grow when
you're comfortable you get fat
it's very simple you know it's very
simple okay when you're uncomfortable
you have to figure out
ways to get out of that situation you
start
thinking your brain starts working
differently you look from different
angles
uh you look at different possibilities
you know your your instincts kick in you
become more sharp
okay so become uncomfortable okay get
into martial arts get into combat learn
how to fight okay it's a big thing all
the sahabas
everything i keep repeating this every
single sahaba
knew how to fight except for one there's
only hassan ibn sabit
who was the poet of the prophet who said
like i can't i can't hold the sword you
know he was just
it was not in his fit right now he just
couldn't do it okay he would say himself
i'm a coward i can't do it
okay but he was fighting the jihad of
the the media you know
he would be he would be hitting the
propaganda
all right but all the sahabah's men that
we love so much you know if you think
about abu bakr you know broke a few
swords okay uh uthman he fought you know
uh omar khattab was was just proper
proper you know combat
so all of them were were tough man you
know what i mean so
it's part there's a difference between
combat and knowing how to fight and
violence violence is something where
you're uncontrolled
you know you have no control yourself
allah subhanahu teach us how to control
enough
and the prophet said is not the one who
over you know who does you in wrestling
or who beats him wrestling is the one
who holds his anchor that you know
that's a strong person right
so we put all these things together you
connect all the dots take the hadith not
out of context but put them in context
then you understand
that it's about yeah it's about a skill
that you develop to become
strong you know so i advise people again
wake up
be uncomfortable learn how to fight
invest in yourself invest in yourself
allah says
you know save yourself first and then
save your family from hellfire
invest in yourself okay uh you have to
learn you have to develop
you know watch what you eat you know
watch your clothes uh take care be clean
care about your look you know groom
yourself the prophet
said allahu jamil allah is beautiful and
loves beauty
okay you know you're supposed to
show the name of allah on yourself you
know allah is as the hadith says he's
happy when he sees that
on his abd on his servant invest in
yourself
you know like this you know this is
women oh he's
he's a narcissist you know i keep
hearing today these women throwing you
know this whole word narcissism he's a
narcissist
he's a so if a man now he cares a bit
about himself and he
pays some attention to himself all of a
sudden he's labeled as a narcissist you
know
and then when the guys are fat and ugly
they're like oh he doesn't take care of
himself i want to
hand some guy i want the air to girl i
want the
turkish drama guy you know who's a
pretty boy whatever you know
like come on man like get you know get
real like you know let the guy take care
of himself you know what i mean
so guys should be handsome they should
take care of himself should invest in
themselves
and when you develop as a real man and
you have the knowledge the
the strength the the the courage and you
you risk and you're not
fearful except of allah it benefits
everyone in this world it benefits the
women
it benefits the children that's the
problem we're suffering we don't have
real men
it's true there are a lot of bad men out
there who are abusing
who are cheating who are running away
from responsibility that is true
some of us were like that maybe some of
us have woken up some of us are coming
from that background
and we know that lifestyle and
alhamdulillah
you know praise be to allah guide it to
this you know but this is the reality
yes there is a lot of bad men
the solution to fix these bad men is not
to get a lot of bad women to balance it
out
you know because women say i'm gonna
also mess around
feminism and all these reactionary
movements oh okay
the solution is to fix the men to fix
masculinity not to reduce it the
solution
is to go back to the quran sunnah this
is what the world needs you know the
world needs
more real men
mm-hmm 100 i mean dude
hold up just to add on to that i think
that not only is it super important
for men to start taking care of
themselves and other men
because i mean masculinity and of itself
is super important
but you outlined the importance of uh
the feminine roles well the femininity
and how like women
women play a huge part in this too
because at the end of the day it's a
it's a cycle
where it's like if you have a man who's
a bad man
he's toxic and that he does a woman
dirty
well then now she's going to become
toxic and then she's going to treat
some other guy who maybe he wasn't a bad
man maybe he was
good at heart and like he was actually a
good man but then she does him dirty
and then now he becomes toxic and just
keeps going back and forth back and
forth so
it's both it's the man and it's the
woman like you said in the beginning
like both of them
have to be worked on no doubt no doubt
i mean look problem with the with with
women
that they're not feminine anymore
they're not taking care of themselves
they're not
acting feminine as as anger said you
know
they get through a bad experience and
then they try to pay it back to the
other i mean i cannot tell you how many
cases i have where you know the woman
just
makes sure that she smears the guy's
reputation now with social media it's so
easy to just push it out on there
oh [ __ ] so i'm sorry this guy's so and
so he did this to me here's a picture of
our chat and
here's this and that let me smash his
reputation what not
uh how many women call the police and
whatnot they say oh
he hit me or something like that or they
use the kids or
you know oh when it comes to their
benefit they use the islamic you know
you know rent right when it comes to uh
it doesn't work that way then they
use the non-muslim law you know so many
problems bro like
i mean i think just yesterday a sister a
sister a sister contacted me from the uk
she's a social worker
and she's putting up and i'll share it
with you guys the link she's putting up
a a conference
it's called something like bitter bitter
ex-wives
she's a woman and she's working with
women and she's like i see
this vengeance in women that they have
to like revenge and it doesn't matter it
doesn't have to be the same guy that
messed them up
they can just they just need to go for
any guy to just you know smash him and
and she said such a big problem because
they're they're destroying lives you
know bitter
ex-wives bitter you know uh sisters
who are attacking men and making a point
to
to destroy their lives because they had
a bad experience you know what i mean
no you gotta you gotta understand that's
thing that's a thing whatever happened
to you we feel bad
but that's not how you fix it that's not
how you fix it you know and
it's it's yeah as anger said you know
it's smashing
the female the femininity women are
becoming more masculine they're not
attractive anymore for god's sake you
know what i mean it's like
so hard to find a good woman that's
attractive these days you know
the way they walk the way they talk
they're trying not to be all cool all
tough and this and that and then the
women are like
there's i can't get married no one wants
to marry me you know what i mean yeah we
don't want to marry a man you know we're
not
sorry we're not gay no we don't marry
men we want to marry a woman you know
one very nice feminine sister
and you know when you have that that you
know that
plus and minus together then boom you
know so but if you have this you know
very masculine female and just this
you know man and then two are just like
not you know not not matching you know
what i mean and the other way around as
well you know
so thanks so uh real quick like what are
your
some of your formal education that
you've had regarding uh
you know university you know college
anything like that
yeah so i've done my degree in biology
psychology neuroscience and cognition
okay and i've done research as i said in
parkinson's
so i've looked at you know human
cognition behavior
family psychology
early child psychology then i've done
education
okay a degree in education and
curriculum
um then i've done a
bachelor's in islamic studies sharia
then i've done
additional qualification in counseling
uh
in existential counseling positive
islamic positive psychology counseling
finishing now a degree in positive
islamic psychology counseling here in
malaysia
doing a master's also in education from
university of malaya
inshallah hopefully finishing up this
year in uh islamic curriculum
and uh counseling in islamic schools
so alhamdulillah i always try to
continue you know like i don't i try not
to stop trying to
keep you know doing something every you
know few years
so
without saying at all that you are well
qualified to talk about mental health
so how does mental health tie into
masculinity
right i think it's it's the
the concept of if we are not
what we're supposed to be that we're
emptied something's missing and when
something is missing
you sometimes you cannot explain what
especially if you don't know so a lot of
men don't know that they're not real men
they just feel so empty they just feel
like they cannot fulfill their purpose
they hook up with a girl you know a wife
or sister who's gonna be you know
wearing the pants
and a lot of guys come to me and they
say i'm depressed
i'm not feeling well i don't know why
like they don't know why so obviously
i'll ask a few questions
as to you know their past their
background their upbringing their family
dynamics
uh intimacy right away that would be one
of my first questions that i asked men
is how's your intimacy with your wife
and right away will be like
non-existent i sleep on the couch man
boy take the couch you know sisters say
like that you know
so and i'm just like okay here we go so
there's there's a void
mentalish mental health
is basically a void within the fitra
okay that sometimes you cannot explain i
don't know
why i feel the way every single person
out of the thousands i've had thousands
the cases
come to me and they say i don't know why
i feel like this
right so there's this void because why
what they're not fulfilling their
fitra they're not being masculine
they're not
guys are in the house now you know their
wives is
subhan allah women are demanding 50 50.
you come and sit and do 50 of the dishes
you know i left for you those two rooms
to vacuum
i don't care you came back from uh from
work and you work your
you know your back off but sheik so and
so said in a lecture
that you're supposed to do half the work
you know what i mean
so the sisters are being empowered today
by imam you know fulan and
they are you know pushing the guy so the
guy is not in his normal environment
he's not in his
his niche you know so he's in the house
you know we're we're
we're lions we're we're wolves you know
we're from from outside
and then you make us chihuahuas you know
you put us in the house and we become
chihuahuas you know
and then of course we're not gonna feel
well you're not gonna feel good at all
you're going to be constricted so men
have this void in their mind because
they
you know they don't feel that you know
we're not out there we're not in touch
with nature
women is different they're fitra they
like to stay in the house
they're okay now of course with the
propaganda they're also coming up with
like i want to do this i want to climb
mount everest
all this stuff you know whatever
but this is not in their fitra this is
not that's why
women don't suffer from so much mental
health
they complain a lot by the way women are
also more
forthcoming about the problem so they go
for counseling they talk to their
friends they backbite they
you know they have their little girl
talks and whatnot you know sleepovers
whatever slumber parties
you know talking about everything and
then they they come back home and say no
we don't do that you know you know we
don't do that it's like it's like makeup
you know it's like something behind and
something else in the front you know
so but for guys we don't come about we
we look sometimes a sign of weakness so
a lot of men hold it inside
so that's why most of the suicide cases
that i deal with are
are men and sadly you know we had a
suicide case just a couple of weeks ago
and now i'm dealing with
another potential one you know men don't
feel fulfilled
they don't they're not in the right
environment they're not functioning
properly
so this is tied to mental health and
those thoughts
that are inside their minds be that
they're from the outside inside or
they're
just being you know cultivated from the
inside for whatever reason
will take them down and again because
they don't seek help they don't come
forward
or when they do it's very late of course
it's going to
affect everything they cannot do well in
their work
they cannot do well in their family they
they
lose their their body their strength
everything
and then they're just another walking
body you know and this earth consuming
and just
you know spending time to clock his kick
you know the
clock is ticking so mental health is a
huge problem i think a lot of the muslim
communities also dismiss it as like no
brother
just make dua you know it's okay read
more quran you know
stuff like that which is okay it's true
but how how do you connect the quran
and the dua to solving mental health you
know
like a lot of imams are not trained or
if they do get trained
they will train in the secular
non-muslim non-islamic you know
way of dealing with right so pop some
pills
you know what kind of things all kinds
of you know freud or whatever
type of psychology or philosophy they
come from
and it's not solving the problem it
might patch it but it's not solving a
problem you know for us we know
that the deen is the solution but we
just need to connect it properly we need
to contextualize it properly
we need to understand how where
why you know the hikmah and i think we
can we can solve it inshallah but
again they're our community this taboo
people don't want to talk about this
they don't want to and and if they do as
i said they will
recognize psychology as a secular
human humanistic study that is somehow
superior
not to to islam you know gabriel on a
side note are you using a microphone
uh yes button what th this one
yes i think it's not working right now
why is it yeah i was gonna say i've been
hearing some like
weird noise i'm telling you who is it
and now i realize
it's your beard rubbing on the mic oh
yeah it's probably from this one
yeah yeah yeah it should be bro
it's the beard man
it's profound to hear this because i'm
i'm pretty open so i'm just going to say
i have no problem with that this is
something i went through right the whole
depression
suicidal tendencies all of that the
whole nine yard unfortunately
you know alhamdulillah for everything i
went through it it made me the man i am
today alhamdulillah and it allowed me
to position but i did go through it so
it's profound hearing it now after i
went through it and being able to
to reaffirm and connect those dots it's
almost as if we have this
biological disposition this natural
disposition this state of being
in which we can either choose to
maximize on it
so it benefits our life or we can go
against it and then that's an uphill
battle
and the issue with that is not only is
it an internal thing
but that internal mentality that
internal state of being
obviously will have external
repercussions outside it will affect
your outside life for example
if you're a person who is a male
biologically naturally
you're a man you're a male not man but
you're a male but you want to act
feminine let's say you get in a
relationship with somebody
a female if you start acting feminine
she doesn't want to be with a girl
so now externally that's going to affect
you and
essentially that's what happened to me
in the past because being raised and i
can say this firsthand being raised with
this westernized
ideology feminism because feminism
doesn't just affect women it affects men
because you can't have one without the
other so if women want to be more like
men that means men have to be more like
women
if you go against that biological
disposition you're literally literally
literally going against your own self
and that is the most toxic and
and that's i'd say that's the highest
form of self-hatred at that point to be
honest
although no doubt no doubt
and the thing with masculinity bro and
this is this is to everyone like
if your masculinity is suffering your
mental health is myself and more
and that in turn is going to make your
masculinity suffer more
and it's just a negative feedback loop
it's an uphill battle from then on then
on
after that point because as we know
mental dysfunction mental
illnesses symptoms whatever it just
makes you more turbulent it's hard to be
grounded
as a man if you want to be in your
masculine you need to be grounded so
having both of them in check
simultaneously
is key as uh brother gabriel mentioned
so in terms of mental health what would
you say that
uh the biggest issues you've learned
from your experience are
for people in mental health what would
it be uh you know
something like uh psychosomatic would be
their diet
would it be something like you know
they're not you know just
present uh would it be heavy reliance on
big pharmaceuticals what would it be
i think it's it's a plethora of things
you know
starting from our environment you know
the pollution
the food that we eat um the
you know the dynamics of our society
like just the the nine to five
driving every day getting stuck in
traffic man you know people are just
dying off right uh peop the way people
are at work they're not happy with their
jobs
okay uh i think the highest rate heart
attack rate is usually
uh uh it's monday morning at seven a.m
okay in the united states if i remember
the statistics correctly right because
people are going back to work
they hate their job you know they hate
what they're doing right
and if you look at it this type of
social
um dynamic is something new it's not
very old actually
um the way we know society today is
something rather new
it's less than 100 years the way it's
set up right this is post world war
ii where things have happened the way
they are the big corporations with nine
to five
with you know factory work on the line
all that right uh
two paychecks you know what not right so
yeah so environment food health
um you know social dynamics
relationships
um and of course the lack of purpose in
life you know
people doing things they don't like just
because we have to do it
you know right and it's it's it's
killing people you know it's
it's people are not fulfilled you know
one of the highest
um you know the most important thing in
the human development
is you know the concept of you know
findings you know self-fulfillment you
know what i mean
being part of something
self-actualization right
in the hierarchy of needs right is where
you
know that you have a purpose and there
are means for you to achieve that
purpose you
feel like you you matter and like you
are
actually on a path to achieve that and
it's not about necessary attainment like
attainment becomes difficult you know
but progress you feel
you can gauge your progress in life you
can see it
you reward yourself you know what i mean
okay i am
doing what i like that is why those very
successful people
in this world you find the ceos and the
people that really made it
that they have a passion for what they
do you know that's number one
most of the people if you ask them all
these great ceos all these big guys they
have a passion
right also you know they have the 5 a.m
club right they all wake up early
you know right i keep telling people
wake up early the process
there's a blessing there's a barakah in
that time
right so oh there's just so many things
that affect
mental health people rely on drugs as
soon as
someone gets a little cough or headache
panadol right right away
it's available at 7-eleven it's
available at every store right right now
so easy people are looking for
quick fixes um it's just there's just so
much and we're not getting better the
world
is not getting better we need to get
back to our fitrah we need to get back
to our
natural disposition allah has created
this system
the human being in a certain way and if
that system is short cut
it's not operating properly it can power
on
it might have certain functionalities
but you're not getting the best
out of it you know you're not getting
it's like a car that hasn't you know
changed its oil you know you got you
didn't change the oil you didn't tune it
up
you're not gonna get the best
performance out of it right
and and you it suffers you can feel
every bump every turn every this
every dab because it's not tuned up we
kind of we're kind of the same you know
allah is created a certain way
and we're supposed to tune up through
tune up our fitrah through the
deen through our you know revelation
through our masculinity
to femininity not feminism okay for
women
and then that's you're within your
proper operating range and you work well
okay you don't work perfect necessarily
not perfect no one is perfect but you
work well
but when you don't do that so all these
factors
what you see on tv what you see on the
internet what you
eat the air that you breathe how much
you stay in the house the fear that's
put on you
you know the news that you read all
kinds of social media the arguments in
the family
the complications all these things will
all make an impact right every you know
people don't understand
the slightest exposure to the slightest
stimuli
will condition you whether you like it
or not whether you're aware of it or not
they do condition you and even if it's a
very slight exposure
and then if you get exposed to a similar
stimuli and again and again and again
then it becomes even more it has a
greater effect on you so
this then in turn leads to mental health
issues
where people have a short in their
system
they don't work properly and you know
for those who have suffered depression
like depression is
is almost
it's quite difficult to to define
unless someone has actually experienced
it
you know so depression is
you know you can't turn off your brain
it just talks to you
it what if this what if that um your
mind
is is is not functioning properly
there's
thoughts that are coming into you from
you don't even know where of course
shaytan is right next to you always
whispering to you
you just you have this feeling
where you don't want to live anymore you
don't want to move on anymore
things that matter don't matter anymore
things that made you happy
don't make you happy anymore some cannot
sleep slump sleep too much
right and you just cannot explain
to yourself what's going on and you
cannot remove yourself from this
from this this this vicious circle of
thoughts and feelings and
you know it's just impossible so the
west obviously will try to
offset this by medicine you know and
then it doesn't work and medicine has
side effects and people who take
medicine they
become like vegetables sometimes i mean
it's just there's just so much
happening when it comes to this cannot
be easily just explained
it takes so much work to deal with it
and
so much connection between a counselor
or a person and you know and i think
that's the best way to
solve mental health issues
is when you connect to someone
and you don't feel you're the only one
because that's another thing about the
pressure you feel that you're alone
you feel that everyone else is having
the time of their life and you are
suffering right you are the only one
that's going through this
uh same with pornography addiction same
with drugs same you know
people you know the shaytan wants you to
lose hope so when you connect to others
who are having problems and who are
you know or have had these problems it
just brings in a bit more
you know feeling like okay i'm not alone
you know in this world there's others
who have gone through it
and it helps but it's just such a
complicated matrix of things
that we really need to pay attention to
the communities really need to focus on
uh we need a lot of workers who can be
trained imams
and so on because they're the first ones
they usually get asked by people isn't
it
right the muslims try to go to the imam
or to the friends and whatnot
so we need we need a lot of attention to
these guys a lot
100 men this will be one of the most
important episodes so far for
our male audience all right
females definitely they're gonna get
some value from their sisters but
this was definitely directed to men
nonetheless
you guys have anything else you want to
say uh yeah i wanted to say for like the
past half an hour that this is gonna be
another one of those episodes where
like you think okay this is a good clip
this is a good clip and then you just
realize
the entire thing is one amazing clip and
you take it all
or you know you can get benefit here and
there but you got to take it all because
there is not
they're literally not adult there is not
a dull moment masha allah and i want to
say i want to add that this brother
as well as the other brothers we have
the podcast up to this point this
brother masha allah
me personally i'm going to say
definitely somebody to look up to for
many reasons mashallah
so forgiveness yeah may allah reward our
brother here allah forgive
yeah i mean so brother gabriel if people
want to get more of you where can they
find you at
okay so i'm mostly active on instagram
and
facebook okay just if they type in
gabriel romani
they'll probably get uh my stuff
inshallah
and you got a youtube channel too i do
yeah it's mostly just for backup stuff
but mostly active on
uh on instagram perfectly i'm just gonna
find you
i'm gonna find your facebook instagram
and youtube inshallah i'm gonna link it
down in the description box
and uh yeah i know man why don't you
close it off for us today
nah yeah bro you had that look on your
face like you've been wanting to close
off an episode
so i gotta let me just let me let me
just add one little
two cents here um i wanna agree
with gabriel with what he said about uh
that we should be training men or we
should
have men that are training you know more
so in the sense of uh
combat because um it's not for violence
it's not so we have
guys out here fighting with every other
guy but it's more so
like can you defend yourself
can you defend the people you're with
like are you secure with yourselves and
let's be honest nine out of ten guys are
gonna say
they probably they might say yeah but
you know deep down
they're questioning their head like oh i
wonder if i actually can defend myself i
wonder if i can
you know take care of these people that
i'm with and i feel like that would be
um not just a big change in terms of
masculinity
but also a big change in terms of uh
the mental health aspect because if guys
have this security in themselves that
like
you know what i can i can defend myself
i can take care of these people that i'm
with
like there's there's a certain level of
masculinity that comes with it there's a
certain level of assurance
and just confidence and overall
well-being that comes with that
so i really do i agree 100 you know
and going back then you know the sahaba
weren't weak
the companions weren't weak like they
were warriors
they did what they had to do and like oh
you have the community nowadays and i'm
let's bro let's let's go even further
than the muslim community let's talk
about just men in general
like nine out of ten men don't know how
to defend themselves
self-defense weapon they're using knives
using guns and look there's nothing
wrong
with knives and guns but it's like
if you only had your hands if you only
had your body what can you do now
and if you have a stick in your hand
what can you do now
you know like can you use whatever it is
that you have with you
can you use nothing that you have with
you you feel me i feel like i'm rambling
here but y'all understand i don't know
i hear him man i hear look guys uh
if you guys remember when uh putting
aside the permissibility of that
when khabib fought mcgregor right
man do you know how many muslims are
watching that fight muslims felt that
that is the
that is the the representation of the
fight between
iman and kufarman you know like
we we as imams and and like we got so
many questions so many
of these scholars were saying you know
what i'm not even going to talk about
the
haram this was a war and we won this war
like
so many ulama bro like people gave
lectures after you know
because so many youth woke up
that next day bro with the sense of you
know a compliment
accomplishment and desire to want to be
better
you know as a muslim and because it's
the fitra bro putting aside the
the environment of the ufc and what
happens and hitting the face and all
that
i'm talking about just what it
represented
you know what i mean so many young men
that i know
connected to that and changed their life
because of that you know
just because you would say you know it's
like
me it's allah or something or makes a
jew or something you know and
it's such a big thing right and i'm sure
i'm sure many men
okay many men are gonna watch you know
mcgregor are fighting tonight you know
i know i know they're gonna watch it why
because
see sadly instead of
using as as angel said using
you know combat for the right reasons
we've made it entertainment and you know
like look you can the fitra is still
there
but it's like what the heck is the
purpose you know what i mean
so we used to have proper you know
purpose for this as the sahabas did
and men still as anger said let's put
aside you know just go to men in general
men have this need and if they don't
know how to do it
and there's no ethics and morals i.e
islam to control it then of course it'll
be like the bar
fights the smashing football games the
ufc's and
all this entertainment stuff yeah beat
his binocular kill them and whatnot
because you know the fitra is going to
manifest
itself you know you choose which way
you're going to go
so definitely definitely this is a very
very important point
wrong quick was the time
it's almost you live in the car it's
like five minutes later i'm gonna let
you ask your burning question that
you've been asking me before you
reverted
oh yeah yeah you already knew i was
gonna ask you right
um i wasn't listening i wasn't gonna ask
this question but it just came up
at a time right the time is now and
gabriel
so big question for you and this
probably does not have an
answer this is probably very subjective
and um we won't have a
clear-cut answer for myself personally
and for all the other dudes that are
wondering this as well
but would you say would you say
that the ruling on the
striking of the face and
no bodily harm do you feel like those
two rulings
are a big contributor to the
[Music]
i guess i could say be lack of um
[Music]
the lack of combat experience and that
self-assurance in
muslims because because
training number one is very
specific in the sense that what you
train is what you are implementing what
you are ingraining in your subconscious
so if you're
if you're training to jab the face and
you're not actually training to hit the
face and you're not training to avoid
strikes to the face
in a real life situation you're not
going to be able to utilize that it's
like above americans said he
he was doing taekwondo for years and
when they sparring taekwondo
they get like two inches away from
hitting the person's face
and he said that he got into a fight on
the street and every time he went to hit
the guy in the face he was two
inches away from his face can you
believe that bro
so if if we're thinking about this if
we're thinking that everything is
ingrained like that
that's what martial arts is and number
two you have to go through
some kind of bodily harm or
to a certain extent in order to
progressively get stronger and be able
to
learn even more it's kind of like
working out you know you're tiring the
muscle fibers in order to rebuild them
and then if just me little like side
note here if you think about the sahaba
when they were training for war like i
doubt they were
not striking each other i'm sure they
weren't using a real sword
but i doubt that they were um using a
wooden sword
and then not hitting each other at all
you know because it's like
you have to train for what's to come so
like do you feel
that because of those two rulings is
actually contributing to
muslim men being a lot weaker and a lot
more
insecure in themselves because they
don't have that combat experience
because they feel like ah well i can't
do this because it is haram
and then now you have khabib or habib i
should say
and you know i'm not not justifying
anything he does
i'm not justifying anything i do it's
just a simple question but like i said
it's a
very subjective one it's a very good
question mashallah
okay uh while i'm talking to you guys
right now
i have a severely broken rib
my left side here it's been two weeks
now tamda is recovering
uh we we spar hard man here at uh izame
um yeah and um look
i believe that strike in the face as for
the hadith
is haram okay but
in the context of just like slapping
someone
hitting someone in the face i believe
that
training is a different context and
if you're not gonna train within the
correct
context within as close as possible to
real combat
you're not going to be able to actually
do anything you know as one of the
soldiers said that we used to train
under the conditions of war
so war had no effect on us you know what
i mean
it was just the same so personally um
what i do i'm not gonna push on anyone
else but i think the the
meaning of the hadith is specifically to
hitting someone in the face just like
that's not about training with the
intention to really
protect the ummah to develop yourself to
protect your family
i don't like to shadowbox i work mostly
bag
and spar because i don't like to hit the
air
you know what i mean so when we fight
with the brothers we fight hard
we love each other we hug at the end but
some walk with a broken
rib uh you know maybe like you know
broken whatever it happens you know but
that's just the way it is we
we try to pad up we try to you know to
to go
not too hard but it's not going to be
light that's for sure
it's not going to be light at all and i
think
you're totally right angel i think a lot
of people because of that
they're not developing themselves or
they're just you know
it's just different man you know it's
different than when you when you fight
properly and
it's not just about the striking skill
it's about the intensity of the moon
there's a lot of guys who know how to
punch the bat but when they meet on the
street if something happens
it's the mental state you're not
prepared you don't know how it feels to
really get hit hard
and really you know as mike texas is
right everyone's got a plan to get
punched in the face you know
everyone's got some spency move you know
or some
spin kick or something like that until
someone actually gives you one you know
clocks you want and they're like oh what
the heck happened you know it's like
different everything changes right so if
your mindset is not trained
for combat as close as possible to the
reality
you're not going to be able to react
i've been into many street fights that's
just the way i grew up
and i've gotten beaten up many times
i've lost a lot of fights
okay i've gotten severely beat up even
though i was
a very very good martial artist from a
very young age
but it was theory and theory
is nothing to do with what happens
on the street and really even sparring
you know it's not the same
when you your adrenaline is popping up
when you got another three guys around
you
and you don't know who's going to kick
you and you know you get tunnel vision
it's totally different so the closest
you train the closest you train to
reality
the better it is you know right so again
i'm not saying to people i'm not getting
a photo i'm just telling you like
this is kind of what i do uh i train
hard
you know sometimes it hurts and
we hit we hit the face we hit the head
we hit everything and
we love each other after and you know
like but man when i walk out of the gym
bro
i feel like a man i feel alive
how many times are you training that
hard
um we spar hard once a week once a week
hard
yeah i was gonna say like you should
definitely periodize
it and probably leave hard sparring to
like once or twice a month
yeah once yeah
i mean i just i feel like
if you do hard spot like that's where
you're hurting each other
like broken bones and stuff like that
then that's kind of like taking away
from your training time
yeah i mean look the the the rib thing
it happened now
i think last time it was quite some time
ago so it's not like
every day or every week that we're
walking away but
yeah i mean if you don't defend yourself
and you don't putting up your
hands properly then you're going to feel
it no doubt
true yeah just to reiterate the points
off
i'll show you guys i'll show you guys
here let me let me take you for a little
yeah go for a little tour with this this
is uh our office by the way
okay this is where we do our doll videos
and everything
and let me just open up the line really
this is our
our dojo here
bag we got you know
wow so you know enough space to spar and
everything it's like
it's quite big we have four bags
and uh you know like our sparring stuff
here and whatnot yeah
that's what's up man y'all know we'll go
crazy in there
yeah i love marshall you guys are
welcome and come come to uh when you
come to malaysia shallow when everything
opens up
we do some uh some nice traveling
inshallah
yeah just to reiterate this whole video
none of this was to constitute any
medical advice
you know there's no licensed physicians
here uh quick disclaimer and no father
no rulings
it's just four brothers just having a
discussion romney you got anything to
say
yeah um i i think i can add to the that
point inshallah so firstly i want to say
that
the the the issue of habib and that
fighting and stuff it's not
just the possibility that striking the
face might be hard on if you take the
entirety of the ufc fighting for money
ringside girls
even men's aura is showing men's outrage
and fighting not for self defense but
just for entertainment
agreed and more are issues
issues i agree they're great i agree
with that yeah so when people say you
know
heavy fighting and ufc this is an issue
it's not just the punching of the face
and also also i want to add in terms of
rulings in islam i want to point out
something very specific the prophet
he sent a group of sahabah to travel and
he said
don't praise salah to the us until you
get there right don't even stop to pray
right and some of the sahaba understood
this as i will not
stop moving and i will not stop to pray
until i get there
and some sahaba understood it as he
means just get there fast
right so some stopped and prayed asur
and then kept going and some didn't stop
some went and they
they prayed us or when they got there
right and ended up missing yeah
yeah so when they got back to the
prophet i said um they asked about this
what did you mean
and he looked at one half the half that
you know didn't pray that walk there he
said you're right
he looked the other half that prayed and
then kept going he said you were right
so it's not always a clear cut this that
the other and sometimes a hadith may
sound the prophet i said i'm saying
under no circumstances can you ever do
this but in reality
as the brother mentioned context is
vital and crucial to the quran and to
the hadith that's why we take
all of it and it's not us it's the
scholars who have been studying it for
a lifetime right under people who
studied it for a lifetime
they take the entirety of the quran as
much as they can
and they apply the proper sciences to
derive a ruling
i just want to add that yeah
i think we wrap it up for today i think
that's uh
that was basically you saying you wanted
to end it
should i end it then all right
okay but you have to you have to what
what should the the people who made it
this far comment down this time
um yeah last time was uh was what
it was a fasting video right
i don't remember i don't remember man
all right if you made it this far
uh write down dojo hashtag dojo
defense is from the fitra
just built hashtag dojo bro cause he
showed his dojo so if they made it this
far don't know because they still don't
know
100 all right bro all right with that
being said
we thank our brother gabriel may allah
bless him check out his socials and
again one more time what was that book
you mentioned you wrote
a journal of a new muslim journal of a
new muslim if you are
interested check it out in sha allah
we'll link that too
inshaallah i personally want to read it
so with that being said my love bless
you all thank you all for watching
till the end this has been a gem allah
bless the brothers here
i mean allah elevate uh everybody and
make us all you know
real men inshallah and real uh and real
women
so that being said allah
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you